Mic Check 1 2 hi everyone so today's
episode is an illustration based on some
of my favorite comments from you guys
always notice how you all answer the
questions for my strangers answer series
in the comments
I love reading them and I would always
think to myself I wish shows away I
could share this on video so I came up
with this I'll be doing the voiceover
and illustrations are done by my very
very talented friend lon she sent me all
day lacerations and I did my best to
animate them please check out her work
when you get the chance I could not have
pulled off this episode without her so
thank you again long ok one more thing
before we get started I want to note
that the characteristics of the
characters are not meant to represent
the actual people but to simply help
tell the story Thanks to everyone who
shared these stories with me I hope
you'll all continue to do so so I can
have more episodes like this alright
here we go
all these comments are from the episode
who's one stranger you still remember
comment number one Walmart love I was in
Walmart I was 14 years old and I
remember seeing a girl she had a giant
scar on her eye and I had a very similar
scar on my opposite eye and I wanted to
ask her so badly how she got that scar
but I didn't ask that day and I thought
I never would but boy was I wrong five
years later I'm starting college and I
go to class a girl walks in and you'll
never believe it it was that girl from
Walmart so after class I went up to her
and I asked how did you get that scar
and before she answered she said I
wanted to ask you the same question all
those years ago at Walmart 20 years
later we are married with three children
thank you
Walmart
comment number two kind neighbor before
I was placed in foster care and then
adopted I used to get food from a nice
man who was our neighbor my older
brother and I were very young and we
didn't get fed while our parents had a
lot of problems I remember my brother
and I would hide behind a tree so our
parents wouldn't see us the man would
then meet us on the other side of the
fence to give us apples from a tree in
his yard along with other food items
eventually our parents found out and I
guess they told the man to stop and that
they fed us well when they didn't
because one day he stopped meeting us at
the fence a few days later we were taken
out of the home I won't ever forget him
comment number three kangaroo man all
these answers are deep my memory is that
one time I was at a restaurant and this
old man waved me over I went to his
table and he opened his bag there was a
baby kangaroo inside a baby freaking
kangaroo that was nine years ago and I
haven't forgotten comment number four
Jack and the Beanstalk
I was in second grade I think and I saw
this boy in my class he had some kind of
disability but I wouldn't know I was in
2nd grade and every day he would draw
the same picture of Jack and the
Beanstalk one day I said want to be
friends I liked your picture and he
didn't look me in the eye or respond but
the next day he drew the same picture
and gave it to me but this time climbing
the Beanstalk was me and him comment
number 5 Eli when I used to work at the
bodega in my hood there was an old man
named Eli he wasn't really a stranger we
saw him every week but he didn't really
talk much so we didn't really know him
every Monday straight he'd come in get
some beers cereal bananas lottery
tickets bread and some other basic goods
I knew he was struggling and very lonely
often he didn't have enough money so I
sneaked Lee swiped my card or just
cashed in and paid for him he always
acted like he didn't see anything and I
would just say it's on the house then he
would thank me sometimes
it sounded a little ungrateful and then
he would walk out one day I was done
with work and I walked home to discover
a big painting laying in front of my
door and had my name on it when I looked
at it I saw it was a big painting of me
and my coworker in front of the store
depicted like some bodega gods feeding
the poor and sharing love while bright
shining light was coming from us with
the text on the back of the painting
saying I thank God every day that people
like you still exist you are my heroes
Eli after that we didn't see him that
much anymore and heard just one month
later that he was very sick and passed
away so we decided to hang the painting
just behind the counter in the store and
to this day it's still hanging there
rest in paradise Eli comment number six
connection across borders this one time
I was driving on zero Avenue on the
Canadian border parallel to the US
border and there was a small stretch of
road running on both sides it was a
beautiful summer day and I was feeling
amazing a car appeared on the US side
impulsively I waved and smiled out of my
window on the Canadian side and the two
guys on the opposite road
enthusiastically waved back we soon
disappeared from each other sight but I
won't ever forget that moment of
connection across country borders
comment number 7 a love story I work in
a restaurant and a while ago this older
couple would come in every Saturday for
lunch the man would pull out her chair
and open doors for her like a true
gentleman while she patiently waited he
had a walking frame so he struggled but
insisted they would order spaghetti and
share it lady into [ __ ] style gazing
into each other's eyes you could tell
they really loved each other then they
would order cheesecake and share that
too one day he turned up alone ordered
the same but only ate half the spaghetti
and one of the cheesecake takeaway as I
handed him his cheesecake I asked about
his wife he looked at me with tears in
his eyes and told me she's in a better
place now it really showed me to
appreciate the people I have while I
still have them comment number 8 we're
all human when I worked in a busy
supermarket I often had days where
customers would look down on me for
being behind the checkout as if it
wasn't a worthy enough job for them to
engage in conversation with me I
remember one day I had a nasty customer
after nasty customer and this one guy
waiting in line had heard how others
were talking to me or just ignoring me
he apologized to me on their behalf he
spoke to me like a normal person and
made every effort to make sure we were
both engaged in the conversation
he then told me that he placed his
groceries up extra slow because he don't
want to leave until he saw me smiling
and that way he could leave knowing that
I wasn't feeling so bad as he walked off
I noticed two giant tattoos on his calf
muscles there were the patch signs of a
well known gang that day forever changed
my negative stereotypical perceptions
and assumptions of all gang members they
are humans too
just like that guy made me feel human
again comment number nine I think she
was a mermaid I used to have bright teal
and blue hair and would make my eyebrows
the same color with makeup and one day
when I was walking around in a store a
little girl just stopped dead in her
tracks staring at me and went oh my gosh
I love your hair you're so pretty I said
thank you and kept shopping and when I
turned the corner I heard her say mom I
think she was a mermaid I felt so happy
because I mostly heard a lot of Smurf
jokes about my hair and criticism about
my appearance in general for looking
unconventional and it just reminded me
of the beauty of a child's mind in that
moment
comment number 10 are you okay
a woman saved me from killing myself she
pulled up to the sidewalk where I was
sitting and saw being and about to run
into the street when she just asked are
you okay and saved my life
and that's all of them for today I
really hope you guys enjoyed watching
this episode because I want this to be a
regular series on my channel and
obviously that's only possible if you
guys continue to share your answers here
on youtube or on my Instagram and
Twitter like I mentioned in the intro
all the illustrations in this episode
were done by my friend lon
so please show her some kindness help me
thank her for helping me pull off this
episode I'll link her social media in
the description and it'll also be
somewhere on the screen probably right
here really cool story on how this all
happened basically a while ago I spent
almost an entire day just reading
through the comments for the episode
who's one stranger you still remember I
took screenshots of my favorites and
shared them on my Instagram but I was
really annoyed because I also wanted to
share them here on YouTube I just hadn't
thought of a way yet so I thought about
it and I thought it would be cool to
have an illustrated episode of the
comments and at first I tried to
illustrate them myself but then it
turned out very good I'm not very good
at drawing yet hopefully I will be in
the future but so I put on my list of
things to do to find an illustrator and
I think it was just a few days later I
went on Twitter and lawn who was a
stranger to me at the time had also seen
the episode and wanted to tweet an
illustration of her own answer to the
question I saw it I loved it I really
like the way she else rated it so I
messaged her and asked her if she wanted
to illustrate this episode and here we
are it's crazy how things happen my goal
is to hopefully one day be good enough
and have my own style and illustrating
and maybe I could illustrate an entire
episode myself but we'll see that's
pretty much it please
subscribe button if you want to see more
of this and other things on my channel
also make sure to hit the bell next to
it so you'll get notified as soon as I
upload here on YouTube thank you guys
for watching this episode thank you guys
for everything and I'll see you next
week